you think I'm popular now wait to [ __ ]
hits the fan you got your prospective
happy happy
[Music]
what can I answer for you so I've got a
good concept of where I think most of
your people are super on really big
businesses in terms of getting the
person you need to speak well why do you
want to get into big businesses because
that's the people already so I think I
totally understand so I think you do it
I you know it's gonna be interesting
there's me a lot of similar answers I
would do unlimited LinkedIn content with
paid LinkedIn ads directly against the
people you want so if you want RBS Bank
I would literally make a video or a
white paper or an article that would
write does the banking community so you
don't go directly RBS because you can
get others does the banking community in
the UK understand on average they're
throwing away 3.7 million pounds you got
to do some homework you know this is
crazy
just last year blah blah blah HSBC
wasted 2 million we've got the solution
and literally I would target those ads
against the CFOs and HR it's interesting
to have Alan here and his HR friend like
literally the HR executives my CFO CFO's
and HR people against the companies that
you're trying to reach and I would do
that 50 times so it's funny that Mandy
here we were filming something the other
day like we're like to me it's all
contextual content against media spend
so what my team is done very well is
they take content I naturally do hence
I'm filling it and then we do ad spend
but then once in a while they'll ask me
to film something and like hey we need a
Instagram swipe up ad for this and then
I like every time you yell at them and
say guys I'm right here so let me
instead of like doing swipe up and buy
my sneakers they can be like hey Mexico
swipe up and buy my sneakers because
just by doing that and then targeting
Mexico the ads are gonna come work
differently so if you noticed what most
people will do is hey London or Britain
or Europe did you know that there's this
law what I want you to do is make
literally the same video eighty seven
times does the bank
communities like you start with if you
notice what I'm doing with the video I'm
not giving anybody a three seconds
hey banking community boom now they're
stopped the title says the wording is
banking this is banking and there are a
banking HR and CFO executive do you
understand yeah
it's literally that and by the way that
obviously as you can imagine works for
most of you you want to get distribution
on a cruise line because you don't have
it for the corn yet you go hey cruise
executives like literally it's really
scary how Universal that advice is but
that's what I would do LinkedIn ads
which are overpriced in my opinion but
are so actually be unfair I call them
overpriced because they have a floor
it's not a marketplace the way Facebook
is say it you know like it's overpriced
in the fact that what's amazing about
Facebook and Instagram and Google and
all the things quant advertisers
somebody who spends six million on
something whether it's I ads back in a
day or in game or whatever it may be
when you we're over him and I are always
gonna love something that starts at zero
and the market makes it go to $80
because moments and time allow for
things to be grossly underpriced what we
hate is the way that you know NewsCorp
sells which is you try to buy an ad and
the Sun and it's 15,000 they've inflated
the floor Guk LinkedIn is an inflated
floor however if you are a beauty be
marketer there is a disproportional
value prop and in essence I even am
correcting myself it's if it's inflated
but it converts it's not inflated by
definition I think it will work for you
media always being a content
you
must be personal unbelievably first of
all you immediately leave LinkedIn you
go directly into Instagram you go to
Instagram stories because I think
they're grossly underpriced and you do
swipe up campaigns against trainers and
as I think we all know the entire
fitness community is living in Instagram
and then again you can do something
literally the content or the
spokesperson addresses a female trainer
a part-time female trainer a full-time
female trainer a full-time male trainer
a part-time male trainer trainers that
work at gyms and you're trying to
encourage them to leave I mean there's
you know as you can see the the big
thing that I don't think people have
understood and to be very frank is now
becoming a new conversation even amongst
my team and definitely vaynermedia
itself is the vulnerability and the
thing that everybody has to close the
gap on is the volume of content it's the
content right like again I'm using him
only because he's so quant based if you
know anything about gaming it's like
it's [ __ ] math what what the math
kids why math kids lose to a guy like me
that doesn't rely on math is I know that
the art is a much bigger factor than
they want to admit because math kids
don't want art to matter and art kids
don't want math to matter but they both
matter and they matter equally and when
I when I say equally if you actually
disproportionately respect the math and
the art equally and you make them play
together like a diamond in that friction
is all the magic for you to the next
frontier is math
is running your paid media better is
targeting employee is it employees is
back on Facebook right Andy right so
you're gonna be able to use employees
like LinkedIn you guys can literally get
every single person that works at IDEO
to know who you are
tomorrow you could and of course
eighty percent of them are gonna be a
lead us and be like [ __ ] these gals but
twenty or not yeah
and in those twenty is a lot of
opportunity for you of people you want
to recruit to work for you one day
because they're tired of that or they
just love you and it's a gal executive
who like somebody comes in and the idea
is too expensive and they're like you
know you should go check out you know
how works got it making sure I need to
know prior what bit send content how
many times and what need to do to that
person and if you want to use them as
the ad a hundred percent supply planning
upfront is the key it's it's a modern
day production schedule that doesn't
exist that we're trying to introduce in
our company which I use an example with
my Budweiser team the other day I'm like
you're gonna have Adam driver the actor
and you're gonna do this incredible
video which they did I'm like but when
you're there my team knows now to make
eighty pieces of content not just one
but I throw a curve bought them I'm like
no no also bring a soccer ball that has
nothing to do with anything and just
like I don't know like kick a soccer
ball at a bottle of Budweiser and film
that too you're there anyway like the
volume is the game so I first got them
from okay Adam drivers here let's make a
one three-minute film that's amazing but
300,000 also while you're there take 88
pictures with him take the scenes of it
create the collateral the sawdust make
94 piece of content cool so we're at
some level there too not there at Vayner
now I'm introducing cool and while
you're there bring an umbrella a soccer
ball bring bring four actors you know
African American Latino you know Pacific
Asian like like leave there with 947
pieces of content around 30
seven pillars of different like brand
pillars not just the interpretation of
the one thing you're doing we're filming
a Super Bowl spot with Charisse Charisse
they're on for a Budweiser like while
you're there for two [ __ ] days
instead of everybody like looking at
each other and [ __ ] jerking off and
doing [ __ ] which is what happen I
literally can't go look at a production
shoot for vaynermedia or any other
production company in the world because
it is the stupidest [ __ ] of all time
like I don't know as to say there's tons
of people I mean doing nothing me Gary
or Boehner both me that's funny you
bring that up because we were just
having a discussion literally as I was
walking in here I would say what so
first of all the team has control of
things so there's certain things that
are being posted I'm completely 100% in
control of my Instagram I'm for the
first time only 98% of the control of my
Twitter because I'm doing this if you
follow me on Twitter this add your two
cents it's longer form Twitter you can't
upload natively anything over a minute
in video so they have to do it for my
four minute clips and this that got me
to the first time ever I'm like you know
what you guys post it and I can't post
it anyway you'll post it but in essence
I'm a hundred percent control of Twitter
and Instagram of that probably I would
say 70 60 percent of what you guys are
sending me I'm posting instagrams the
funny debate because I'm spending a lot
of time there and I have to really feel
it and in their production a lot of
times they'll miss what I'm feeling and
thus I won't put it or I'm cool with it
perfect which is easy or I figured out
how to support it with the copy that I
write to make it post but you asked a
very important question
one would say oh my god I have 20 people
working designers video people they're
working all day they're making stuff and
I'm only posting half let's go with that
that's unbelievably inefficient I would
argue it's not I would argue the fact
that we're just making it's unbelievably
efficient that if even if I don't post
it and then that's why we created the
team garyvee account
because we're like [ __ ] we have it well
let's post it somewhere so that's been
working like to me versus me coming in
and being the bottleneck up front I'd
rather just be the Tollbooth at the end
and then be thoughtful and see how I
evolved by me being smart of not being
the bottleneck up front which is what
everybody does because it's all ego and
as a human it's really intensive but
even as brands adidas or juice or corn
like they it's all you go things don't
get posted people overthink the living
[ __ ] out of the content they post like
it's completely insecurity it's
overthinking it's it's all bad
and then what we did was we evolved and
realized oh [ __ ] even in the 50% that
were not posting we figured out a way to
innovate and create team garyvee to post
that so we became less inefficient
that's your answer
yes you've gone you've gone there and I
think and listen and and I know that I
could have I really wish I could have
told everybody what I thought your
question was gonna be because I knew
this was gonna be a question and you'll
never believe why it was why I listened
upfront you know like there's a post
time right now where I'm really
interrupting somebody and I always laugh
I'm so good at listening it makes me
seem like I'm not listening I'm always
interrupting because I want to get to
the value punchline like I knew you were
gonna ask that because you said that
people are making hundreds of thousands
of dollars on the back of your thing so
I knew that you cared about it and you
were worried about it and then that was
your justification to why it's okay
I know I'm right but it makes me happy
because it means your intent is right
and that already means you're good so I
talked about not monetizing my audience
but I need to do a better job of
clarifying it and that's why these
settings are good and it's why my
evolution is good for example a video
about to post Oh a hack we came up with
literally just a week ago was we
realized that we thought about before
but we got serious about it just maybe a
week or two ago they are no longer
titling any of my Instagram meme content
I am that's where I was getting hurt it
didn't feel right and all I have to do
which takes time that I don't have is
now they're sending me the raw videos
I'm titling it setting back then we're
setting it back and we've seen real
success in that I titled one yesterday
on the way to London called when you
give give when you sell sell so a couple
things one I don't monetize my audience
but I'm very comfortable to ask for
people to buy sneakers books and sunna
wine so I do it's just I don't monetize
my information which is a clarity you're
in you're monetizing your information
which I don't think is a problem I think
the reason I feel so good about what
you're doing is I can tell your intent
is right and the only vulnerability you
have and I don't sense that either from
you is you just have to not be full of
[ __ ] yeah that's all
I don't have to tell you like like the
reason I push so back on you know people
monetizing is I'm going after the lowest
common denominator kind of life coach
who has nothing to bring and went to
like a top of the funnel conversion
conference and wants to just be that guy
we know what we're talking about you
guys are professionals you did something
it's look this took me this took me
years to do this what I'm doing I don't
feel unbelievable about everybody here
pick it had to be vaynermedia not me
you're all here because of me I then
call worst it to be more vaynermedia
which on that 10,000 that I could keep
for myself I'm getting you know 187
bucks after prop you know and that was
important for me yeah I'm okay with that
but I needed that even though this could
be a 50 million dollar bit like my whole
life could be this more like like I can
have the biggest mastermind of them all
so you have to be okay with it I am okay
with this and I'm not okay with a 50
million dollar mastermind yeah I feel
like if you feel if you you feel like
you have a skill set I think design
Sprint's is a very good genre I think
what you need to think about is where
you're gonna get caught and a couple of
you is always think about brand over
sales so for example you're busy now and
you've made hundred and you know how
long have you had the thing over all
know the whole company itself right so I
know I know I'm about to jump in in six
months for you to generate something
that creates half the revenue of
something that six years old it's not
and think about how easy it is versus
how hard the other half is it's going to
do what you're gonna go through is what
I go through every day this whole thing
the entire Vayner ex world not just
vaynermedia the pure Wow stuff the 137
and you'll be seeing me announce a lot
of companies in the next six months it's
all not smart in the short term finances
for me none of it this has been a waste
of my time for the last seven years of
the prime of my career you don't like
giving up you know 36 to 43 during an
economic
the discipline it's taken me to know
that I'm building a framework for 50
years during a very good time in my life
which is also forced me to travel while
I have kids I'm in my prime I have
plenty of energy I'm not sick
everything's good this is golden years
like you can do a lot of damage and the
economy's been frothy scum buckets are
making tens of million on cryptocurrency
fraud right so so though I will never I
will be so revered in 40 years when
people look back at the level of
discipline that I deployed during the
amount of opportunity that's in front of
me that's what I want you to do what do
I mean by that while you make your
product better run ads to convert more
and all that stuff you're equally to
really answer your real question have to
allocate one to two hours a day to do
podcasts to put a flag in the ground
around design sprints yeah which bring
you zero our ally in the short term yeah
not your podcast though you need
distribution you need to go in other
podcasts and spread your message message
it's okay to sell as long as you're not
disguising it as you're trying to help
people yeah like I love selling but just
don't be full of [ __ ]
like I love when I go into sales mode
cuz some of my fans get really mad and
I'm like I laugh I'm like no no I'm not
making you buy this I'm not one of those
funnel people where you come in it seems
like I'm giving you good information
then it stops and says and if you want
the real real good stuff put in your
credit card and get the next two hours
of this video no no you're more than
like I'm pumped that people have never
bought a bottle of wine from Wine
Library a sneaker from k-swiss and 4-d
he's like I'm thrilled don't even know
don't spend a second on it have no
knowledge just know how big my audience
is computer to my conversion and I know
a whole lot don't doesn't even cross my
mind got it yeah when you give you give
yeah when you sell yourself don't mix
them that's why I wrote Jab Jab Jab
right hook some people most people sales
people needed to learn about jabbing
but ironically a lot of very awesome
people and very sweet people and very
good people really needing to learn how
to sell like they're like your model
doesn't work I'm like did you ask to
sell anything
well no I'm uncomfortable to ask I'm
like that's your problem like if you
always give and never ask
and it's ask it's not take it's not
steal it's not manipulate it's not
cohort it's not trick it's ask like in a
month you're gonna see I'm starting a
wine project I'd like you to buy it if
you don't you know like I don't know
it's we're back to our scheduling
regular program of like free content
around business like if you buy watch
like sneak why I like sneakers is like
people buy sneakers so like if you know
like if you're like if I if I brought
you value if there is a brand
Association if you've liked the way they
look and it's a 50-50 toss between you
normally wear adidas and you're willing
to buy k-swiss well that's a good thing
that's how I can get that sale but it's
not like all of a sudden tomorrow I'm no
longer putting out the level of like all
of a sudden you notice I'm not putting
out content anymore
it's not as good when I do it feels more
promotional to something that's coming
and that is to be paid for it be like
what you're doing all of a sudden that
was a pay-per-view show not just the way
you've got it if all of a sudden you're
doing this if you're doing it for just
brand which it seems like you are and
it's gonna be on YouTube and Facebook
then that's great but if you if all of a
sudden it wasn't and it was $9.99 to
subscribe to it that would be like oh
[ __ ] that feels a little like you did
all what people don't want is you did
all this for this you were tricking me
so sometimes people interpret that when
I'm selling sneakers and I jump in their
comments I'm like you're a [ __ ] idiot
I'm like you're that's why I went so
hardcore between you know my content and
the things that I sell that's why this
was harder because this is far more
associated than sneakers and wines which
is why I had to make it Vayner not me
makes sense see the patterns
yeah this question that's what this is
for and he's a person who's quite
someone to use and he is handsome so
we're we talked to me about this is a
new dynamic there's a CEO to this
company
you're both employees of this company I
understand you have no I quit either one
of you in the company yeah good so he is
like high energy like very intelligent
super so each daughter every time has a
lot of ideas right a lot of people have
company I think everyone how many people
are in the company containers and a lot
of people are gonna be find actually
quite difficult to to work with him make
sense if he comes in it's a scrubbing
yes around and yells ideas at you and
you're like great yes so what I'm
wondering does he does he do anything
practical I mean this is a really
important question and we won't use it
like this I need the answer to this like
I do that but what makes me palpable to
my team is I also do practical things
thus it offsets it becomes more creative
and entrepreneurial versus disruptive
and a clown and a caricature I'm in HR
meeting some in finance meetings I sell
I like you know like like people take
credit for things that I actually did
because I did a meeting at 10 o'clock to
midnight with an executive to get us
that business like when put when we when
we go naked
all of a sudden vanilla realize for
example it took people at a while people
like you guys and the outside would say
Gary as the CEO vaynermedia has people
running that company and he's Gary Vee
what people on the inside know is not
only is that not true and I'm the CEO of
the company I'm also really the CEO Oh
like if you asked Alan you know you know
we're seeing like if you ask him he'll
tell you like I'm the CEO and CEO that's
what makes me being ridiculous palpable
I'm actually executing okay that's a
very important thing that's where people
like me are accepted by the Ord
versus not like what's our best way to
like I don't know do best at the company
if if we're constantly kind of feeling
what does best mean does that mean why
do you want to well is he you know this
is where you know so it was really
interesting somebody uh somebody I made
a decision yesterday on the flight out
here to never say that I have
narcissistic tendencies because I say
that at times about being like an extra
burden being out there somebody left a
comment in a YouTube video that I was
reading yesterday that said [ __ ]
narcissist right in a negative way and I
was like huh sometimes I say that about
myself it might be a good idea for me to
actually look up what a narcissist is
and when I looked it up I was like oh
[ __ ] I'm only four of these twelve
things and that eight of them are
terrible like insecure fear like like I
was like I'm not that at all and so I'm
like I'm not gonna use that anymore I'm
gonna stick more within extrovert
because I'm giving permission for people
to believe that truth when wow I didn't
realize how off that is for what I
actually am this is leading me to this
question this why I painted that picture
is this an individual that you can have
a Candra skon verse a ssin with or will
that be the worst
yeah well then you have to that's your
answer
yeah the answer is you don't debate it
here in a in a conversation the answer
is you sit down and have dinner and say
we're at a crossroads where we think
this company is going to the next level
we US maybe they're the third we think
we're a big part of it I want to be
unlike I like you and you're likeable
and I want to be here because my main
question is why do you want to because
my main thing was like why don't you go
do this yourself but if you're gonna do
it with him because you do see the
values of it you articulated whether he
changes or not it's on the record it's
something you can point to on Thursday
if you and I have dinner and you're like
Gary you get a little ridiculous
sometimes and like and so like then I
come in and start getting ridiculous and
you can look at me and I'm like oh [ __ ]
you're talking about last Thursday
dinner aren't you it helps you haven't
laid down the context you need the
answer to your question is radical
candor you know so I think you have to
do that I think the question becomes
that can go one of two ways it
unbelievably works with me I love when
people come with radical candor with me
for two reasons one 25% of time they're
right 75 percent of time I can tell them
what's actually happening that they're
confused by right when you have
employees like we like everybody here
judges me but they have no context and
it's not their fault I'm not I don't
think they're stupid I think I'm looking
down and they're looking up when you
look down from an airplane at the UK you
can see a lot more than when you're in
this office so I love it because 25
percent of time they can see my humility
and I'm appreciative and I can see their
smarts and we move forward and build a
real relationship 75 percent of time it
reinforces my genius or uniqueness to
them because you pick somebody smart who
cares who's willing to give you radical
candor and then you throw something at
them that they never thought of and
they're like [ __ ] that's true [ __ ] it
gives them confidence in their leader
it's an amazing I only I tell my company
all the time I want to be the reverse of
the Emperor with no clothes because the
second you walk into my office we've won
it's using me 25% you're 100 percent
right and you can see my humility and
acceptance or 75% of time you're
walk out being more confident in me you
should have that meeting to figure out
if that's the framework or if it's
insecurity which leads to like get the
[ __ ] out of here you know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about when you own your
umbilicus different I can say when you
own your own business you'll understand
in a far more professional way by
bringing them respect and explaining it
to them versus being hyperbolized in
that moment yeah and I think it is
difficult but I think you know for me
it's why I'm successful like everything
good should be difficult you know like
when people like man you deploy so much
humility for your position I'm like yeah
but that's why I like just starting the
hardest things lead to the best results
[Music]
I mean my biggest worry is losing
somebody who's good because they're
confused on what's going on but that's
on me not on them yeah and just knowing
that I can't get to everything all the
time always but I can to the best of my
ability and and that's that but at 18
it's like I would rip my arm off to have
18 employees to be so easy
you could feel socially if you had to
blow the social media team of three
people over there we'll see writer
creator of video and pictures and
distributor of the content with a
backbone and paid distribution a writer
a creative who does video and pictures
everyone one person has to write yeah
one person has to create the video and
pictures and one person has to know how
to distribute it contextually to the
places where the attention is yes I
would have that person ground in the
paid I mean everyone's ideological about
organic but to me it's like when a deep
when there's something to buy that's a
deal and you have the money and buy it
and that's what I think Facebook and
Instagram ads are right now d-roc who's
like and the way I look at Barack is I
do think video and and and create
pictures what am I looking for graphic
thank you I think video and graphic like
I think people separate those two I put
them in one but I do not think somebody
that has a crater buy or as a designer a
videographer or designer let's go very
literal I do think it should be in one
predator right you know you know produce
at it be like in one I do think and I've
seen with the Iraq and others Caleb you
can video you can post produce a video
you can also make pictures I believe
that is one person it is more rare for
that same person to also be a great
copywriter it is more rare for that
person to also be able to be great at
Facebook and Instagram ads or
distribution that's right so I'm
comfortable in those being your very
literal answer those that is the
triangle and when I talk once all
depending on how happy you guys watch my
content about my twenty person team I
know I only need three
I do 20 because I want them to all
disperse into other parts of the company
eventually and I'm doing some other [ __ ]
like random stuff like but yeah when I
hear people like that's the team that's
the triangle but but they're there
transcribing from videos into a LinkedIn
article like you know that kind of stuff
somebody had to write that 88 page deck
that we may put out again you know you
gotta put words to things you got to put
pictures and videos to things you have
to know how to get people to see them
very basic no I'm saying three people
should do those things I listen there
you know what's ironic I was that person
I was that person at Wine Library that's
what was so hard for me I'm vaynermedia
I did everything I didn't know there was
and then there's also strategists like
probably the like the most impactful
thing I do and I think the thing that
Andy has developed into is there's
strategy to like what do you what are
you doing Klink and then there's macro
strategy of like shouldn't you guys work
there like it gets really like you know
or like where you could see where I'm
going like I'm already like cool I know
what you're about to ask but also like
strategy is like dude you need to create
a product line named after your
grandfather or daughter and [ __ ] put
real 20% energy always because what if
adidas sells to [ __ ] supreme in six
years and the cancers contract always
run by the way I hate when when
uncertainty is the driver to that um
it's always makes sense but in my
keynotes I always say raise your hand if
you're having your best year people
raising their hand I'm like you're the
ones I'm most worried about
notice how uncertainty got you to oh
[ __ ] we should have a hedge I'm most
worried about everybody here who's doing
the best because they're not thinking
about hedge cuz it's working those that
sales machine is feeding me that company
signed a six-year deal with bless you
six years is like [ __ ] in six minutes
I'm aware like I see it every day you
know what I'm good at is pattern
recognition of business over the last 25
years mine and others I've done bless
you small business family business I was
in Silicon Valley I did Madison Avenue
for a reason
I knew nothing about corporations I
couldn't speak smartly seven years ago
about Nike and Adidas now I can tell you
everything now I'm dangerous now I've
got the blueprint across all
entrepreneur SMB Silicon Valley tech and
fortune 500 now I understand everybody's
strengths and weaknesses now I can start
my career at 50 that's the plan so when
I talk about patience I'm like think
about what I just said and all the while
the most important thing that I want
people learn for me didn't make money
build a business for my dad had no money
vaynermedia my brother Steve Ross not
making any margin not making money not
making money up to 50 I am people like
pool how do you have a Hamptons house
how do you like yes I'm making money but
I'm leaving 90% of the economics on the
table and so cool I'm talented so I had
bigger numbers but like it's still the
thesis so if you're not as talented as
me and you're making 50k when you work
400 K but if you follow my model you're
gonna make four million now you can get
hit by a tree you could die like I
understand you can get divorced and lose
half and like change your date like
there's nothing that's foolproof but
there are it's I always use Fitness
because it's easier for people to grasp
like if you eat right and exercise look
yeah you could get cancer you could like
you know you might have a body like I
don't have a body type for a chest do
dust like like there's certain things
that are gonna happen like I'm putting
in the work but I'm not gonna have a
nice good chest do doesn't does like one
pushup it has a chest
he's putting in real work but but
there's body types we all know it right
like some people starve themselves and
still or chunky and big boa but but but
the reality is do it there is certain
things that are black and white right
learning context thing understanding my
biggest concern in this macro room is
the economy has been good economy isn't
good for a decade globally you know
every markets a little different you can
see little different in London the US
but like in the macro the whole world
has become full of [ __ ] and doesn't want
to pay the piper and that's gonna like
we should absolutely on merit have a
global depression because the whole
world is full of [ __ ] and that could
happen like I think a whole lot about
like the biggest thing that keeps me
safe is I'm willing to live in this room
with my family and that's cool that's
why that's why I'm pushing everybody not
to be fancy because I know they're about
to have to not be fancy they're not
gonna worry about [ __ ] Yeezys and
Supremes and gold watches they're gonna
be worried about [ __ ] putting food on
their table like that gets real like
that's a that's a spectrum boy like go
read the Roaring Twenties
go look at everybody in the world lived
in the 20s you'll get real scared real
fast you'll get real scared real fast
because you know how the 30s and 40s
clean up we're headed so I think like I
think about a lot that [ __ ]
I think that's keeping me up at night a
little bit about next year a week where
we're marching on to practice it
whatever your views on it there is a lot
of uncertainty in the service business
yeah that's one kind of pivot business
even that's gonna be in fact and let me
tell you why I'm so happy to push
everybody here on building a personal
brand it is the best asset to have
during a shitty time cuz you'll be able
to get a job like like what what will
work for you by building an HR personal
brand is god forbid when it all hits the
fan IBM still may hire you for 50 cents
on the dollar of their last HR executive
but you'll be at the top of the list
like like if you really play a
depression immigrant like doomsday model
like I do okay I'm like old school
[ __ ] Eastern European like I've
cashed buried in the backyard [ __ ] I do
like my financial advisors gets so mad
at me they're like you're so right about
so much you could be making so much more
money if you didn't take that kit why
don't you take that cat you're publicly
saying to invest in Netflix and Amazon
you're sitting on cash with no interest
if you would have put that into Amazon
and Netflix you'd have twice as much
money I'm like yeah but guess what I
slept really good at night because if
the whole [ __ ] world collapsed I know
I have a million bucks in cash which
could be worth $38 but suddenly more
it's still gonna be better than zero or
negative zero which everybody else is
gonna go to because everyone's
over-leveraged that's the vulnerability
of a young kid that hit the right timing
yeah like you're not going to find any
investor you're not gonna be the
property you invested in that was prime
goes to very low god forbid you have any
loans like people don't get it I'm not
want to talk about that [ __ ]
yeah I mean and then the other thing is
that's why then I money's one thing
because of all the money's worthless
there's that it's mindset it's like
really getting to a place that you're
okay
in living a peasant life I mean it was
just yesterday
money to me you got an investor we built
a business we have huge 1994 we started
we are sick finals - it's huge and the
biggest thing that happens in cpgs in
today's Rolex the biggest reason I left
VC Silicon Valley and push against it is
everybody thinks that's the right thing
to do it's not that they don't even it's
not that they're like they don't even
know any different like there is no
under 35 year old in the world that
thinks going to a bank for a loan is the
move everybody over 50 thought that was
the move yeah and because they don't
realize what's happening like Gavin will
tell you I was in nourish like you get
kicked out of your own company yeah
people don't understand what actually
happens you won't live we look and I
apologize real quick and also what
happens is you're building a company in
a fake environment you're losing money
every month but you think you're
building something then something bad
happens you have to raise more capital
and it changes the cap table to you
getting paid last and then your company
sells and you made no money people are
not smart I know what to say
and so like I have a communication style
that penetrates and so I'm trying to use
it for good like to help people because
you think I'm popular now wait to [ __ ]
hits the fan I'm gonna be the most
popular cuz the 10% that are live are
gonna be alive because they listened to
me and did something completely
different and the 90% which they
listened to me for six dollars just to
like you know like that's you know yeah
or just to that's how much the market is
in a melted down world but sixth up you
know I guess what six dollars acts like
a million because everything comes down
together and I think it's twelve dollars
not six you know my great moment in my
career will be the next economic
downturn because yeah please because I'm
not building an agency because I'm
building this for internal IP and then
I'm gonna convert it inside out so
here's what's gonna happen when the
world melts AT&T and BMW and Evian and
Tesco or all gonna hire vaynermedia
because what's gonna happen is their
marketing budgets gonna go from a
hundred million to twelve and they're
gonna need that twelve to work really
hard and we're established as knowing
how to do that and the only reason
people don't go with us now is because
money's easy and they don't have to do
the right work so they can give the
money to their buddy or the person that
takes them to [ __ ] in the Manchester
United game on the field got it when
they can't do that anymore they're gonna
give it all to us I'm gonna get all that
so this machine that is stupid now gets
really smart because we'll go from 280
to 590 in revenue in 24 months it'll be
profitable revenue because the world
will melt and I'll be able to hire all
the people from other agencies for 25
cents on the dollar at the same time a
bunch of companies are gonna be over
leveraged and I'm gonna go out of
business and I'm gonna be able to buy
those businesses with the cash flow of
the 590 at higher revenue then the
economy should turn back in 12 years and
I'll be able to sell those businesses at
the frothy end and buy the Jets
Super Bowls you see what I'm doing I'm
playing the reverse game yeah so
everybody thinks it's stupid now because
they don't understand it's over valued
then it's gonna seem very smart and then
I'm gonna show this video be like it
wasn't an accident which will only
compound the smarts of it and I'll be 62
and have 40 years to play all in the
equity of like pulling off a
billion-dollar thing on smarts not luck
on humility of eating [ __ ] for a decade
in my prime right like kids are gonna
watch these videos and be like he was
[ __ ] 39 he was 42 like I'm 26 and he
was patient that's why it worked I'm
gonna do nobody's ever seen anybody play
it we didn't get to watch Steve Jobs his
first nine years and not that I'm mad or
this and that it's just like we didn't
get to see Bezos packing books no
powerful and B right now how many views
do you think how many you know how many
views do you think if Jeff Bezos was
doing a blog those first 50 episodes of
impacting books in a [ __ ] garage
would happen 80 million maybe a 14
billion right everybody would watch it I
mean everybody yeah so how'd you like to
watch Michael Jordan's first three off
seasons and the work he put in so
there's a lot of thought that goes into
what I do that I don't speak about or I
show glimpses of and things like this my
team talks a lot about like me not
talking about being smart as you guys
know like none of my content is
predicated on being smart that's just
gonna speak for itself when it's all
said and done I don't need people to
think I'm smart
I'm excited for that time that you talk
about obviously can be taken for the
negatives around back we'd be looking at
an investor recently yeah not in effect
capacities for someone's but someone she
prefers to buy the company yeah but
we're not ready yep and then we'll have
a good buying the small percentage yep
could we get a cash injection yep like
we've zeroed out your tax return rate
but if we didn't quit saying yes like a
scale like hyper scale this year is a
line graph to advise yeah I mean look I
think I think it all depends on the
terms of the deal yeah like I've been
vaynermedia you know just a brussels
[ __ ] and 40 percent of my company
it just I've never had a meeting with
him about the company yeah so like if
you take a million quid and you never
have to answer to anybody like like to
me the biggest reason not to take an
investor is prepping for a meeting every
quarter yeah good
Alan will tell you that I don't need
want to talk to him it's my own CFO so I
want to navigate and not answer to
anybody like if you have to answer to
them why you did anything that becomes
an energy suck yeah and was it worth the
Quinn yeah okay cuz all you're done
talking about is generating your own
cash and just being slower which nobody
wants cuz they always think it's a land
grab I never think it's a land grab I
think when you're good abundance is
always the answer yeah everybody always
justifies to me like no no Gary you
don't get it this moment in my business
right now I get cool yeah I'm like it's
never a moment dick there's always a
moment there's always an angle retail is
changing cool retail would change
tomorrow like there's always a [ __ ]
moment you know
[Music]
approaching us on our agency site about
doing like creative capital projects
where we work with them and immediately
Curtis essentially an investor because
we've created strategy and early they
said no financial exchange they're just
like creative councils where essentially
could be when you say we the company or
you to individually yeah I think that's
that's you know that's training the
special sauce for a percentage of the
upside that you don't open even control
after you're gone don't love it let me
keep going with what do you have I think
under said reaches its limit and us for
us has always been a program we have
ERISA faith in the US food distributors
I decided to cancel distribution in the
US and re-engage with our own
distribution channels and all these
repeater so we are all interesting
and only focusing on one sport which one
boxing mmm
because this on the only other it's a
retailer and we can control I'm said too
many expenditure and what are you guys
doing director consumer in the US
socially I mean we're going to open a 35
and focus on Amazon right that's exactly
right we are but right now we are really
reading the brands are spending our
money
rebuilding adidas boxing yeah basically
so we are sponsoring athletes sort of
charity everyone's trying to and gay
couldn't easy questions where should I
put most of my my Facebook and Instagram
and YouTube and podcasts and long turret
longtail influencers so there's a trend
obviously the u.s. right now in boxing
around things like rumble like pretty
girls boxing like you like you getting
like you giving $3,000 to pretty girl
with 900 thousand followers on Instagram
versus you giving it to Anthony Joshua
or Wilder or [ __ ] you can't even
imagine the Delta there's no up and
coming even Oscar De La Hoya in his most
up-and-coming moment there is no boxer
that even remotely comes close to the
arbitrage of building brand that you'll
get from for attractive people on
Instagram right you're just building
brand you just want attention influences
influencers at scale and original
content at scale created and distributed
on Facebook what vaynermedia does
Facebook and Instagram so we have to
cooperate and sometimes being too
corporate in boxing for example good
luck authenticity yep you created this
sandbox that you plant because you think
it's what the US wants if you blew it up
and did something disruptive that looks
completely different and then started
precedent knew you would reinvigorate
the relationship right now your
great things that you think they'll say
yes to but in reality you haven't
approached it through a creative lens
that doesn't look like how you or you
put in all that effort to counter your
point which is right or you put in all
that effort and they say now because
Karen at corporates like no hence why
it's not fun to be at the mercy of
somebody else that's it because you're
right
but you're both right I don't know I'm
Karen might say it's awesome which you
might not but that is what you should do
and I think ultimately that's what's so
great about entrepreneurship versus
corporate the reason a lot of small
companies do win is they do what you
should do and big companies do what
you're supposed to do 100 percent 100
percent but one more time you are adidas
boxing in America yeah for all intensive
purposes so I think to Nick's point I
think you have an upfront meeting where
with a plan B that is really compelling
like you just you you have an upfront
meeting of like we need a meeting and
specifically about social media content
in the u.s. around these boxing we want
far more creative control and let's just
have a meeting to be aligned on what yes
and no because we're this is you now
we're playing on their design guys some
old rules but we may not even know and
we know we want to go somewhere
different
so let's have that meeting like who's
approving the content has to prove the
content you post on Facebook
good then you should take advantage of
it cuz that's the best thing that's
going on because Facebook ads for
business I've never been better and the
fact that people are walking away from
it is great organic may not be better
than ever
but ads are [ __ ] amazing
the layout complexity that we have to be
portrayed in ask us ever I know man
I mean vaynermedia doesn't do anything I
believe in I'm being dead serious
clients have too much control
again that's a game but that is what you
should do patients know Facebook and
Instagram and YouTube content unlimited
contextual to the paid media
distribution against it
content unlimited to the paid
distribution against it that is the
[ __ ] statement and nobody's doing it
and I'm as a human probably doing it the
most out of any human and I'm not even
she not even remotely close to what I
should be doing I should be running an e
how many pieces of content do you think
I should if you've been listening for
the last three minutes in this context
how many pieces of content should I be
running as Instagram ads swipe up right
now you think how many singular
different pieces of content and then
media plans against it that is exactly
right
the actual infinity we're running how
many things in swim ads right now
swipe ups right now zero one yeah wait a
second
three three we should be running nine
hundred eighty-seven thousand no no I'm
really this is like real talk there's
three pieces of content that we're
driving to which wife said three but in
those babies of commenters fifty
different ways that you could spice it
there's that keynote him saying a
college athletes watch this or a
students of this College of philosophy
yeah literally I should be in studio
right now be like LSU fans watch this
the Auburn fans watches University of
Michigan watch it like literally that's
where this is gonna go well
which is why machine learning and AI and
all these other things in content will
play out over time
because the level of scale the problem
with those things is you're gonna lose
some authenticity yeah but maybe not
because for example if it's voice over
if if I have voice over technology that
can basically make me say anything
because we have so much record like
there's a lot of reasons I do the things
I do that I never talk about why am i in
perpetuity being filmed I believe we
have an audio database now that can
manipulate me saying anything so now you
can imagine I can have an intern make
four hundred seventy eight thousand
College logos where you can hear my
voice say hey UNLV running
fans you should watch this video though
I've never said it but you could see
where I'm going it's very powerful
well ad petite doesn't happen in the way
that I just played it out because I'm so
contextual with that you're only seeing
it once that's what he runs into he has
ADD fatigue because he only has one to
seven to nineteen to thirty three units
people are getting hit with the same
stuff it's fatigue but if it was
contextual in the first place of like
hey Garrett Haake nod Z you were born in
Belarus we want you to play this game
from the Ukraine like oh [ __ ] okay it
was so contextual not play the cat what
Neo Geo games like you know like you
don't get that you don't get fatigued
when you're contextual at scale god
forbid you actually get it mapped then
you hit me with the seven things I give
a [ __ ] about all contextual now you
can't not not get me I think it depends
on the business for you I would pry I
would probably ah it's tough I mean I'm
very bullish on Facebook because of its
pure scale instagrams there too depends
on you know I'm always thinking brand so
you know it's it's like moments in time
make sense huge mistake because if you
run ads against your content you'll
destroy it on Facebook alright let's
keep it going here
very quick question quite specific we've
bottomed the course most way to deter
video of course six module takes you
from like a light paper through to an
action plan we designed it for
individual as an HR director as I was
designing I realized
my valuable and five HR directors CEO
excessive layoffs yep we just find the
Oxfam as a partner who will use its part
that heart placements it brings love it
so my challenge is I still want to sell
to individual your b2b and b2c no
different than him yeah yeah to separate
audiences to different yeah
executions yeah so in terms of b2b
enterprise using LinkedIn as the
platform and Facebook because you can
now target based on employees so imagine
running an app so you make a piece of
content video picture now the copy says
your financial service employees make
sure your chief people officer sees this
and you run it against the seven biggest
financial employees of the seven biggest
financial firms in the UK and so now I'm
a finance manager at Barclays but I seen
on my Facebook feed and I'm friends with
the head of HR and I literally just
forward the link that's why it works but
notice what I did
creative that is contextual to the
distribution I know that I'm going after
employees of financial services not just
the HR individuals thus my copy said hey
employee make sure your HR PC R I'm
going this is why copy is the great
underestimated part of the current state
of creative we've become so visual
we grossly underestimate the copy you
and everybody else
that's if you notice it's so subtle why
is some of the content work because I
could figure out the copy to make it
work for my audience even though the
visual didn't support it as much as I
wanted that's why when I'm that's why
when I post when I'm not tired and I'm
fresh it always does better because I'm
unbelievably thoughtful what I've just
watched the current feeling I have to my
audience the copy that's why my copy has
gotten progressively longer on Instagram
if you followed me for a long time
oh say me that swish a year and a half
ago you know but then I keep breaking it
up I just did something the other day
with just one word and it worked like
you know some like really trying to you
know audio was only copying okay listen
to your podcast loads but that's coffee
that's paying for hot stuff and then go
into that well that's right which is why
it ended up working right and and and
that's right and it would be way better
if I had time because I would record
something original what my podcast would
explode if I had time and maybe I'm
trying to convince myself right now to
do it if I would record literally just a
minute or two to set up what you're
about to listen to because I could use
the moment and talk like on you know on
Monday I can use those i Geist I can say
something like you know I'm trying to
think about the world right now like the
Jets are one and three and I'm pissed
I'm talking about being pissed that's
gonna matter to the audience because it
feels fresh
by the Austrian hmm in time to Germany's
desire yes so the the biggest struggle
right now for me is user acquisition and
engage users especially off of the run
that you've just had yeah because we
looked through a golden year of
opportunities and some of its getting
corrected yes and we're all playing one
big game of cat and LTV he's just
playing it literal yeah cost of
acquisition lifetime duh it's true Maxim
which is why you can get to a hundred
because what it really works you can you
can't spend enough yes you spend it all
it all pays back if you don't and what
you love is this will make sense to you
this is probably where maybe I can take
you to a places that's basically what
I'm doing as a brand in perpetuity
because I have no short-term metric
actually two questions one is influencer
yes we just started working with them
yes especially for Pocket product which
is pretty small in comparison with all
the others what the best strategy for
our business to work with Ethan your
best friends and influences is just
brand longtail arbitrage they won't
convert you like even if they're like it
will you'll find you'll find people like
you like like if I did an ad right now
like hey vaynernation
like straight up being off then like let
me play it out exactly hey vinter nation
being authentic you know I never pitch
anything but the fact of the matter is I
love this wine app like they're my
homies I've known for 13 years they're
paying me 200 thousand for this I want
to be authentic with all of you but you
[ __ ] know me like I've never done
this I'm doing this because this is the
best wine app I've ever seen
link is in my profile you should
download it it would convert what I just
did would convert still not that great
definitely not to what you would care
about and I'm extremely rare thus you
can imagine why I'm worried about
influencers for people that are deep
deep quant based around gaming I like it
better for fashion retail I like it
better for consumer packaged goods I
don't love it as much for gaming because
the natural influencer isn't
there you know the the fashion vlogger
gal there's a billion of her like the
food people there's a billion of them
the I'm a casual gamer influencer
doesn't exist you're not gonna get
eSports people to convert so you've got
a you've got a child you see where I'm
going
yes sure there's people you can do sure
some of them will work format for you
none of them will work the second time
none of them none of them they don't
have a second post in them I think you
need to look at Instagram story
swipe up ads have you guys look at yes I
would I would spend I think what you
need to do is optimize creative that's
what I mean yeah I saw you back here
contextual and scale yes at scale and
building brand I think the two things
that if I was and I think you already
picked up on it I think you're here and
I want you here I want you to spend more
money on brand which will always work
and I want you to go way more longtail
contextual creative and paint this
worked but it's starting not to which is
why this matters yeah yeah that's it
and then I will markets pretty funny I
would say funny is always an interesting
adjective so we're doing social cuz you
know there is no real money involved the
people spend in real money but they're
buying tokens that's right I've been
talking to the game that's right and
that the market is growing while it's
growing because people stop flying to
Vegas they stop playing in the real
casino they stop paying thousands of
dollars and start paying hundreds of
dollars for the same emotions the same
dopamine and the the the only struggle
is the were to find these people and we
meet right the influencers who are
filming themselves in the casino
I had the big queen and stop but it
doesn't pervert so similar to what I was
telling him which is you're going to
many people go to literal when all
you're trying to do is buy underpriced
attention yeah right yeah so so for
example I think you would do so much
better with you know and this is for
your business and this is for your
business the person I'm most obsessed
with is the alpha woman in a suburb I'm
obsessed with this woman I really got a
I'm gonna name her maybe any Sally you
know I just have obsessed with the
following woman high net specifically
because it's more just very general High
Net Worth suburb of a big town she's the
alpha of her 39 friends cuz there's a
million of her and she's so influential
and if you can get thirty nine of them
in a concentrated area you can get the
whole damn thing god it's a cutie pie
law you know and whether it's twenty
eight of fifty five or seventy two there
is a 42 year old woman who is the alpha
of her neighborhood which means 19 other
women look up to her she says they say
they're also influential
boom and it will work for a lot of
people she there was a term in American
politics called soccer moms
it was Nora I don't know if it was
Clinton or bush or Al Gore but it was
like it was categorizing like the swing
of this election is soccer moms which is
really in a lot of ways what I'm
referring to now the influential
suburban woman how she voted and how she
impacted the boat I think that person
right now is extremely relevant to me
here's why I love it all of them are on
Instagram here's why I like it more they
all have between 700 and 7,000 fans
which means nobody's paying attention
it's not fun cuz it's long tail and it's
a lot of hand-to-hand combat but what
you end up realizing is you hire three
people to do the hunt and hand combat at
45 thousand a year hand-to-hand combat d
MD MD
but when you when you amortize out the
cost of 150,000 on salary that's what
I'm doing right now I have three
full-time employees right now DMing with
me see seed on it to every single person
that follows me that either has a
hundred thousand followers and then
scram or is verified which right now is
to what how many people who have left
any six thousand or twelve thousand so
like so right now in my right now I'm
being cc'd with influencers where
they're being sent to fill out a forum
to create a first party CRM for me to be
able to activate them like God I'm not
like God forbid whatever I choose to
activate them on it's going to be really
good it's gonna be really good
the best part for me is I have leverage
with them unlike you going or you going
cold these are people that follow me
that I've probably brought value to so
like I see whatever I ask is gonna
convert at least the first one you know
I have to find my cadence have come not
asking too much but it's gonna work
building that out scaling the unscalable
is always the answer once you hit
attrition and it's super countercultural
to people that are quant oriented
[Music]
okay way to talk about this will branded
a token mountain like the company grind
oh my own this you the human because you
the human then has in perpetuity the
leverage and all of a sudden the
platforms are are courting you not you
the platforms good Gary if you've got
well yeah I I would say that you need to
both go you both have to do the same
move which is you need to go to your
partner be like look I want to go see
Gary me I believe this is right for our
business I would love for you to do it
as well I don't want to do this and you
think I'm trying to do something for me
and not you and you know and I'd love
for you to do it and you may or may not
want to do it but I'm doing it because I
think it's leverage its leverage for our
business but it's leverage for me in
case of who knows what you should do it
too they'll be like well you're [ __ ]
extrovert oh I'm introverted this
[ __ ] like or they'll be like cool
you do it or oh yeah I'll do it too or
like there's a million things that will
happen in my case yes you're gonna lose
the brand around this discotheque market
in the software product yes I need to
build up yes reason I'm the on my
personal site I'm like to recover
database that's amazing what is it was
stuff like I would put all I would put
it all in one place okay and nobody
wants to and it's where all the actually
said oh brother I have good news for you
anybody who doesn't do business with you
because you weren't former addict also
has somebody who's gonna do business
with you because your format it's a net
net score of course and I get it and
everybody's got their version of it yeah
everybody
the only reason not to build a personal
brand right now for real is if you're
doing something terrible in the shadows
of society if you're if you're if you're
if you're if you're cheating on your
husband if you are if you've raped
somebody who stole money like the only
reason to not build a personal brand
today is if you are currently doing
something bad
yeah well because I do get awareness
you'll get exposed what about that
amenable stay though because I've
obviously my masters and they had to cut
some phonetic public domain so I thought
my finance and video because it was
easier and put on YouTube it's easier
than writing for me so I did that and
some of the feedback I was getting
theirs
oh wait cut me deep a nice I said then
nose I don't think I'm gonna do this
again I get it's not just ego or yep
insecurity yeah yeah its value it's
about its valuing other people's
opinions more than your mission people
in real life in real life so instead
about something outline it's not true
because that is really no that's not
true it is real life I'm I see one on
the one-to-one basis if someone said
that to me hacker
discuss with them and I'd feel
comfortable I understand I understand
why it is you can discuss with them too
if you go look at my first book crush it
there's a ton of negative reviews and
then you'll read me replying to that
person you're more than welcome to reply
you can discuss with them it's real life
you could reply to their reply and
everybody gets to see it which shows
humility confidence empathy it's
powerful trait I love feeding my trolls
I think you should feed the trolls
people tell you to ignore them I don't
because if you ignore them then you can
become delusional and get high on your
own supply
I love the negative feedback because it
keeps me not in check because most of
negative feedback is a exposure of their
insecurities if somebody takes the time
in their life to consume your content
and then leave negative feedback they're
in a really bad place
I have nor the time to consume anybody
else's content or the interest in making
somebody feel bad that's the punchline
so I think it's I would tell you it's a
strength yeah okay first of all to truth
second of all it's nothing to be ashamed
of third of all it's inspirational
fourth of all there's other former
addicts who are decision-makers we're
gonna support you in a tie I saved a lot
of it as well in the past activity
wasn't finalized around then another one
we did and all that [ __ ] where's no you
need to centralize the whole breath
everybody's been trying to be full of
[ __ ] like it's just not gonna work okay
there's nowhere to hide yeah so it's not
in terms of like actual business things
so how much would you is there a number
you think we should spend in terms of
percentage of revenue on Brandon what do
you think though so as much as they can
afford this is miss you guys mm-hm
literally I mean it as much as you can
afford on brand it is the it's the most
honorable thing do you think there's
going to be a place where like I talked
earlier right man today people
conferences events webinars stuff like
that whereas I think that would be cuz
young generation coming through and to
see imagine with positions there's
potentially going to be this play around
maybe Instagram or something whether we
even maybe the video content on LinkedIn
but something different like people in
my space
you gonna scroll down LinkedIn to see if
any video or cool video about our
product doing yes we do you start yes
you do
nobody's doing it and every time
somebody does it it works exactly and
that's kind of people are humans yeah
people are people
just cuz they're in LinkedIn like it's
because they're not being fed it guys
I'm one of the fastest growing accounts
on LinkedIn in the world I'm cursing my
ass off and I'm like you go read my
comments on like then half of them are
people mad at me for cursing across yeah
listen listen by the way meanwhile I
just said that meanwhile I just told D
Rock and and II go literally literally
is so crazy so meta guys I want somebody
on the team to go look at the 50 best
performing videos of my career and I
want you to be pout the curse words so
we can distribute those because you've
got to respect the context of the
platform but I'm not scared like
literally I'm gonna do both literally
I'm gonna post on LinkedIn the [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] that and [ __ ] this and then the
same thing like a week later of likes
beep-beep-beep-beep
like cuz they both work you many people
don't work with vaynermedia because I'm
Gary Vee a ton do you know many people
do a ton
gotta let the chips fall if you in your
heat this is your strength
yeah the more you vanilla down the more
you're like oh you're that guy yeah a
suit and tie and good school and you're
a professional and like okay cool
you know like people are running away
from their leverage because we're trying
to be like everybody else
last question I think so my type of
business where we waited quite a lot of
digging - laughing we're like right now
because of this you I'm double largely
for example but Matt you like to double
again it could be half um we're just
single the money in and throws the chips
on behind
roll the dice I guess and I think it
comes down to spending less money on
dumb [ __ ] and dumb [ __ ] a lot of times
in the early days is your own salary the
biggest massage the biggest mistake the
biggest mistake small businesses make if
your company is doing less than 10
million dollars a year and you're the
sole proprietor the biggest mistake is
extracting the money out and buying dumb
[ __ ] yeah
so we stopped at like like a new one I
actually thought we were going to take
out all the loans and stuff right but
already cuz I go to CFO wouldn't have
stopped me in these straightaways like
this is common lifestyle business this
all this money needs to go back into
groves and stuff so I think we I turned
that corner mentally never I'm not gonna
have everything today this new usually
would be in like five or ten or 50 years
so cool cool thank you yes versus
another you have to do both aggressively
yeah so the reason we decided as a new
shorter I know why yeah cuz we don't
have you have to do book it because
we're so I didn't know about you still
have to have it in your DNA I don't care
if anybody I don't care if nobody buys a
single thing from you I need you to have
it in your DNA because Amazon will put
you out of business you will get sucked
into Amazon and you will die
so it's a big focus on Shopify a huge
focus on all three your own dtc Amazon
and retail all three fronts you have to
play and you have to play them like this
because I know you don't have unlimited
resources you have to play them like
like this do you understand
moments in time never ever I didn't say
what most people do you understand you
have to or you will lose that's right
but you saw how I did it right it wasn't
like it what I also didn't say right the
first example is the example you know
the first example is the example got it
and if you're not committed to all those
three you will lose I believe you will
lose I believe you'll lose because the
other two have too much leverage I was
just telling Nick this morning I'm
trying to really think about starting a
company under Vayner X built for SMBs
because vaynermedia is not built for it
beta is mentors is like we have versions
of it but their nuance is part of a
bigger machine I think they need to be a
separate machine built for and so I'm
spending a lot of time on it but there's
another way look I listen I think one
thing you'll appreciate I don't need
anybody here to work with Boehner like
maybe we help you hire somebody maybe
Robby Deeks who's here and is really the
econ guy of our team maybe he just gets
a drink with you and Nick will set that
up so like we're you know of course we'd
love to but like I'd rather help you
introduce somebody for 45k that can be a
Shopify Amazon expert internally like
I'm not you know I'm not that's not
something I'm super worried about but
I'm unbelievably worried about you not
being deeply religious about retail
Amazon and Shopify equally period
and then go back to where a state
country to raise money yes so you're
raising money to you can I tell you how
I think you should raise money from high
net individuals high net worth
individuals who don't want to say a lot
everybody it's going BC VC your network
you know work you know you just live
life you take a step back first of all
you have to recognize that's the right
move strategy now that I've said it now
you go okay how do I do that
okay I could join a country club
you could my uncle's rich let me ask him
and his friends my mate from university
was employee number four and Instagram
got it I think it comes down to the
individual look I think the number one
thing in the current state the new VC
that took away from being a bank is high
net worth individuals who don't want to
say anything let me give you the perfect
person trust fund baby bury trust fund
baby bury to me is the number one person
he's 29 his granddaddy did it all he's
super insecure because all he's done is
hook up with chicks in Ibiza but he
wants to make pretend that he's done
something so where does trust fund baby
berry go investing what is trust fund
Barry want to possibly invest in
something cool that is super up his
alley cuz all the pretty girls like that
kind of stuff and he gets to say that
he's the investor of it trust well baby
Barry does not want to go to meetings
and look at Excel sheets he just wants
to be on a boat and mikonos saying oh
I'm the investor in that corn [ __ ]
trust-fund baby berry is your number one
target yeah and then and a hundred
thousand pounds to him is like when he
spends on sneakers in a week and he has
no context for money you know I'm a
tough high net worth individual cuz I
came from zero and it all means a lot to
me though I spend it like a trust fund
baby I get mad at you when you lose he
won't even remember because the ROI was
just being able to say that he was an
investor that's correct yeah that's
right
and it could be through networking or it
could be going to cool places it just
can like I this is where I love strategy
if you're tell me you're an entrepreneur
and you have a lot of money and I make
fun of the Hamptons and Ibiza
and Mykonos but if you told me I'm
spending $4,000 to go to a music
festival in Ibiza strictly to find six
trusts but now I'm like you're smart you
know what I mean so it's all strategy
yeah entrepreneur that goes there too
like goes to the Hamptons to take a
[ __ ] photo on a swan cuz it's cool I
hate that person because they literally
did it just to be cool and they're
enjoying their lives while they're using
money each month on the back of BC's
money going to Mykonos to get four
people to write you $250,000 check
because they're insecure and they need
to make pretend they're doing something
with their lives that's really
interesting
I wanted money to pay the media I didn't
I my brother wanted money I want to buy
the Jets Steve Ross owns a dolphin's
offered me money at a very high
valuation that allowed me to extract
money out so my brother could get some
money okay
and I didn't it was the worst business
deal I ever did of course I would and it
was just not a good financial deal but
it was the deal that I needed to do for
checking two boxes one getting into the
NFL family early and getting that
fraternity to really accept me in 39
years because I've been around cuz cuz
just like adios like it's so funny I
just know what the game is which is even
if I make 7 billion dollars which I will
because that's on me
they may vote me out and I'm a character
I'm gonna be very public to get there so
I need them to like me not hate me
Mark Cuban doesn't only Cubs for one
reason the other business baseball
owners didn't want him in Mark Cuban
should own the Cubs right now he made a
bid he had the money and they kept him
out another guy so I'd made the deal
because I know what I'm doing with my
life
macro strategy right kill two birds with
one stone my brother got money I got a
valuation that was way higher than an
agency or a VC would have given me so it
felt a little better on a bad deal
because I knew exactly what was
happening and what I was gonna do Ross
is the best he's an 80 year old version
of me best men super nice guy doesn't
give a [ __ ]
pure entrepreneur like doesn't want to
talk about anything in detail it's all
macro macro macro everything's [ __ ]
will kill everybody there's nothing to
talk about
a photo where you have to run okay get
up yes guys well I just what is my next
thing Alan yeah know what oh [ __ ] okay
yeah yes sir yeah thank you firstly it's
been awesome so thanks so much
Terry some other donating apology
violence always worked very well here
because the personal brand I'm really
excited by the way on that note because
it's important
there's a single reason why I'm winning
I've only given advice I've lived
through it is the best way to go about
it if you decide to build your brand in
any way yeah don't reach don't assume or
guess or borrow I know nothing about
what anybody else says I know nothing
like you'd be blown away by how much is
he I've never consumed anything of
anybody just always give advice you've
lived that's why people get benefit from
it you've already seen it work and then
when you get good and realize what
you're unique about so that you can
hedge it because I'm like oh I'm
extroverted so this won't work for an
introvert or I'm high-risk this like and
then you get better at the way you give
it because you started nuancing it yeah
go ahead so even got a personal brand
I'm really quite excited about the yes
challenge yes a lot of people really
excited about it I've no idea how I'm
gonna document it I don't know what I'm
gonna do is by blog style or a
professional documentary with net and -
both yeah get Nick a Rick have two
different films like people and like
make both have him post produce a
documentary yeah and have Rick do the
vlog okay and do you do twice yeah have
their lives I'm going
I think you both man yeah I think what
you'll need to do for the documentary or
the thing that's a longer production is
find an angle that isn't being played
out in day to day and vlog so that it
makes the core group want to watch that
as well yeah needs to be a behind the
scenes maybe yeah maybe right maybe
you're like maybe you're Gary Vee on the
blog but Gary Vaynerchuk in the
documentary like the documentary of me
you even I've given you a lot of glimpse
to it here like all of you are like oh
[ __ ] yeah right the smartest of you in
this room like oh wait a minute
yeah like it's way more serious than I
actually thought yeah because I've given
you four or five data points to like
show you I'm like showing you a little
like that got it you might be able to do
that yeah you might be able to star in
the blog and be and be the master mind
behind it yes in the doc and what you
can do in the doc then is also say and
look let's not forget I did come with my
knowledge yeah I started at zero like
yeah I can start at zero and win every
time too because I've got the IP yeah
that's the difference okay look like
without you acknowledging that it
undermines your entire premise yeah like
cool you start at zero you [ __ ] have
ten years of experience you know exactly
what to look for yeah that's why I can't
do it I'm kitchen mom Susan I don't know
[ __ ] about ten years of experience yeah
it could also be a launching pad for you
to put out three content of the nuances
of the ten years sure okay
see where I'm going I love that really
yeah no yes would you be able to give a
shout out to more followers sure no
problem we're doing right now we do the
crypto every so call
[Music]